and speaking of the president he is now
renewing a promise to end the 18 year
war in Afghanistan by reopening peace
talks with the Taliban
moments ago Air Force one landed at West
Palm Beach Florida after the president's
surprise trip to Afghanistan where he
made that announcement during his visit
mr. Trump also served Thanksgiving
dinner to US troops and met with the
Afghan president mr. Trump also
confirmed plans to bring thousands more
troops home you know the president made
his first-ever trip to Afghanistan in
the middle of a tense period with
military leaders in Washington are we
judging is in South Florida where we
thought the president was going to spend
Thanksgiving we Disney back at his
resort yet good morning David he is back
this morning after a whirlwind
top-secret trip that as you mentioned
marked his first visit ever to that
combat zone he spent about three and a
half hours on the ground before flying
through the night the president says the
Taliban wants a ceasefire adding fresh
optimism that America's longest war
could come to an end the trip was so
closely guarded that even Afghani
leadership didn't know about it until
Air Force One was about to land
president Trump's surprise u.s. troops
at Bagram Airfield in Afghanistan with a
Thanksgiving visit serving Turkey to
troops the president also met with
President Ashraf Ghani before announcing
the US has restarted peace talks with
the Taliban which once harbored al-qaeda
mr. Trump was set to meet with Taliban
leaders in September but caught off a
meeting at Camp David declaring
discussions dead after a Taliban attack
in September in Kabul that killed an
American soldier it's not a good thing
they did with killing a soldier they
want to make a deal so we'll see what
happens if they make it fun if they
don't make it that's fun mr. Trump also
told reporters he plans to reduce the
number of US troops in Afghanistan to
8600 down from about 12,000 currently
serving in the country though he did not
offer specifics we'll be down in a
number that's very that's a good number
and we're gonna stay until such time as
we have a deal or we have total victory
the visit happened just days after he
clashed with his own military leaders
back home President Trump fired his Navy
secretary Richard Spencer on Sunday
after Spencer refused to cancel a
military review board for Navy SEAL
Edward Gallagher who was convicted of
posing for a photo with a dead Isis
fighter the president restored
Gallagher's rank a move Spencer
criticized in an interview with CBS News
on Monday well what do I stand for
Secretary of the Navy go to order and
discipline of the United States Navy
that's a prime tenant this in fact
erodes that a president Trump did not
say how far along those discussions are
with the Taliban or how long they've
been going on but the president is eager
to fulfill a campaign promise to
untangle the u.s. from foreign conflicts
like we recently saw in Syria even
though military experts warned
withdrawing troops prematurely could
make the u.s. less safe Michelle a
difficult task indeed thank you Joe